[Aplausos]
[Música]
o sistema imune sistema imune é parceiro
pode ser um parceiro do câncer
essa é uma questão que surpreende a
muita gente e causa espanto pensar esse
tipo de coisas por isso resolvi trazer
isso e contar pra vocês uma história que
eu acho muito interessante a gente
costuma pensar direto que é de se
espantar que a gente pensa que o sistema
imune é um sistema que defende gente
então vamos imaginar que o nosso corpo é
um castelo que é suscetível a diversas
alterações e agressões que podem vir
tanto do lado de fora quanto de
organizações do lado de dentro
dentro desse castelo a gente tem os
guardiões que são as células do sistema
imune a esses guardiões eles é fazer um
rastreamento de tudo o que está
acontecendo nesse castelo tempo inteiro
mas eles não fazem isso sozinho eles
precisam de um coordenador que é um
linfócito que é um linfócito t um tipo
de linfócito t
esse coordenador é tão importante tão
importante que quando ele falta
o que acontece é que as pessoas adoecem
o melhor exemplo disso é acho que a
imunodeficiência causado pelo vírus hiv
que destrói os linfócitos as células os
guardiões estão todos lá mas não tem
coordenador e as coisas funcionam
bastante mal
então além disso uma outra coisa que a
gente precisa pensar é o sistema imune
usa sempre uma mesma estratégia para nos
defender de tudo que acontece com a
gente um exemplo assim bem é simples a
gente tem uma dor de garganta começa
aquela coisa que está ardendo e essa dor
de garganta pode evoluir para uma
amigdalite que eu acho que quase todo
mundo já deve ter tido em uma amigdalite
a gente sente a garganta ficando ela
fique chato incomoda para engolir parece
uma bola aqui no pescoço da gente
subindo e descendo
vamos chamar isso de fogo por outro lado
se essa política consequência na verdade
de um resfriado resfriado vai aparecer
ea gente tá espirrar manter coriza nariz
vai fundar o olho afirma já estávamos
mas isso de água tá é tão aqui a gente
pode responder àquela pergunta será que
usa sempre a mesma estratégia acho que
fica meio óbvio que não dá para usar a
mesma estratégia que usa a mesma
estratégia para te proteger do fogo e da
água por fogo seus a água pra água você
usa alguma outra coisa né quando de chão
balde enfim rodo outras coisas
diferentes que não são fogo e como é que
o sistema sai o sistema imune né os seus
guardiões e esses reforços sabem que
estratégias que eles vão usar na verdade
parece uma coisa muito maluco que eu vou
falar
mas quem dá a estratégia é o próprio
agente agressor então o agressor dá uma
dica para o linfócito que vai coordenar
esses guardiões e aí a partir dessa dica
na verdade o reconhecimento do que está
acontecendo de estranho naquele lugar é
que esse coordenador consegue
estabeleceu e montar uma estratégia
adequada se for água é uma outra
estratégia que vai ser montado nos
parece uma coisa louca né
é a mesma coisa que a gente dizer olha o
cara vem a saltar e o assaltante não é
que está faltando ele fala pra você qual
é melhor você bater é que você tem para
se livrar dele mas é isso mesmo que
acontece e funciona e funciona super bem
deixa eu fazer aqui uma é ponto a as
três coisas importantes que a gente
falou até agora pra gente poder entender
a relação do sistema imune com câncer a
primeira coisa é que o sistema imune
pode usar diversas estratégias
diferentes para lidar com diversas
coisas diferentes
existe um coordenador um desses
coordenadores muito importante olhem
foto ter que a gente já viu quando ele
falta a pessoa tem a aids é uma síndrome
de imunodeficiência e quem destruir se
coordenador é o próprio agente abençoe
que a coisa doida mas que funciona e no
câncer como é que é o câncer não adianta
nenhuma não tem foto lá ele não faz nada
tá quieto escondido
vamos ver primeiro um pouquinho de
comércio câncer se forma que estou
mostrando um tecido ser um tecido normal
talvez um revestimento de uma
coza né da boca por exemplo ea partir de
agressões diversas e fatores genéticos
uma célula de tecido pode sinalizar e
essa célula tem vantagem de crescimento
mas ela não é autônoma como a gente
pensa ela não faz tudo sozinho
então à medida que ela vai se
desenvolvendo ela vai contando todos os
elementos que estão no entorno do tecido
para conseguir nutrientes proteção
daquele tecido e wii chegará a fazer
vaso sangüíneo que na verdade é uma
ajuda que alguns guardiões que estão
representados aqui ó
é essa são capazes de ajudar ele a fazer
vaso sanguíneo é muito importante para a
nutrição deste tumor e os nossos
linfócitos
também estão lá mas esses reforços estão
lá e não fazer nada
vamos ver como é que é isso no início no
início da formação moral e o foto chegou
neste tumor
nessa fase inicial lembro que eu falei
que ele não é autônomo copa todo mundo
no entorno
o entorno todo consegue dá a dica pra
esse linfócito praquele recrute e ative
células do tipo células matadoras essas
células vão liberar algumas células
tumorais mas não todas como falei elas
são heterogêneos também entre si não são
todos exatamente básico e as que sobram
tá vão se multiplicar escondidas é a
parte do sistema imune
elas não conseguem gerar mais essa
resposta de intoxicação da cidade e isso
faz sentido um processo lento que vai se
adaptando
no início algumas células conseguem ser
visto sistema imune acaba com essas
células e quando ele acaba com a oficial
na verdade é que já está selecionando
algumas células que consegue sobreviver
apesar da presença do sistema
imunológico
então como é que elas vão fazendo ao
longo desse tempo ela ficou mandando
outros sinais para os linfócitos e eles
vão se transformando em células outras
nem vão recrutando outro tipo de
resposta e traçando estratégias que na
verdade ajuda o tumor é se manter essas
estratégias vão ser outros de gerar
guardiões que não vão funcionar
o livro coordenador instrui outras
linfócitos e outras celas daquele
organismo para suprimir totalmente a
resposta imunológica na verdade bloqueia
a ação dos guardiões ou ele usa
estratégias que são de modular é de
nogueira dá dicas pra esse sistema imune
para esses coordenadores de forma que
eles montem estratégias que são
biologicamente importante para nós mas
que neste momento são estratégias que
ajudam o tumor a se manter ea crescer
isso tudo é um tumor primário na verdade
o tumor primário o grande programa do
tumor primário aquele é um iniciador de
tudo mas sem se fisicamente ele não é um
grande problema a maioria dos tumores
primários podem ser retirado
cirurgicamente isso resolve o problema
em grande resolveria o problema do tumor
primário em grande na maioria das
situações o grande problema é que o
sonho de todo o tumor é fazer metástase
então o sonho de todo o tumor primário é
colonizar todo o organismo e se espalhar
por todos os órgãos
esse processo é um processo que não é
simples porque o tumor está essas
células tumorais que atravessa muitas
barreiras aqui cair na corrente
sanguínea
essa corrente sanguínea tem muitas
intempéries que atrapalham a
sobrevivência dessa célula tumoral até
que ele chega no órgão alvo
ele chega no órgão alvo e aqui é o ponto
que eu acho que o mais difícil para o
próprio tumor é se estabelecer um órgão
que não é o órgão onde eles origem como
é que a gente sabe que esse tipo essas
coisas acontecem né gente prestar
atenção é o tumor de mama ele manda
metástase pra pulmão osso sistema
nervoso central e silva
quanto amor de próstata um manda de
taxas para a fibra do osso e pulmão mas
também manda pra desculpas figura não
está boa pra mesmo império está próprio
peritônio membrana que recobre todos os
jogos da nossa cavidade abdominal
então na verdade os padrões de metade
deles são diferentes entre os diferentes
tumores e nem todos os órgãos são
suscetíveis à colonização metastática
isso na verdade foi uma idéia e surgiu
em 1889 por um pesquisador inglês
chamado page
e o pedido que ele viu depois de
examinar mais de 700 autópsia
era aqui tumores não faz imitações para
qualquer lugar e alguns tumores têm suas
preferências de órgãos para fazer metade
e com esse ele fez a hipótese que a
gente chama a gente não eles o amor ea
gente continua chamando decidem só eu
que é semente e solo aonde a célula
tumoral que vai fazer a metástase é a
semente o tecido que recebe essa semente
é o solo e esse solo tem que ser fértil
para essa semente especificamente
conseguir crescer e aí aqui daqui pra
frente vou mostrar pra vocês os dados
que a gente tem gerado um laboratório
eu falei para vocês que o tumor primário
tem muita dificuldade de sair do sítio
primário e scialoja num outro num outro
ter sido eu acho que dá pra gente assim
pensar nisso de maneira simples um tumor
de mama
a célula do tumor de mama nasceu na mama
tá sendo takô pisando e sendo ajudada
por todo o ambiente do tecido mamário
que tem a ver com a alimentação
essa sala sai de lá viaja viaja viaja e
choroso o osso faz um monte de coisas
mas não tem nada a ver com a amamentação
não precisa de alguma coisa ali e como
eu falei também de novo só para reforçar
essas células não são autônomas ou se
precisa de alguma outra coisa ali pra
ajudar esse tumor é se estabelecer pelo
menos no momento inicial pelo chegar a
um ambiente que a gente chama de risco
de hospitalização e os linfócitos
diferente da célula tumoral são os alvos
que círculo e circulam livremente na
função dela está embutido essa
capacidade de ser fã do que a gente viu
que essas células chegou no outro que os
linfócitos então que foram é desculpa
que foram é que receberam as dicas lá no
tumor primário depois utilizar cresceu e
está super estabelecido eles viajam pela
corrente sanguínea chegou no osso
arquiteto mostrar pra vocês como é a
estrutura interna do osso estrutura
interna do osso na estrutura trabeculado
quando estes linfócitos serão lá se eles
forem em fotos que foram instruídos pelo
próprio tce
né a desenvolver é todo um programa de
estratégias que pode interferir no
metabolismo ósseo
esse osso vai ficar assim todos buraco
cavado e nesse processo de consumo acho
que gera essa perda de osso
a gente tem liberação de muitos
nutrientes dentro do osso que vão ser
úteis por o tumor
então depois que isso acontece na
verdade o linfócito prepara esse nicho
que a gente chama de pré metastático
acontece antes da metade do que
acontecer e com isso o tumor passar por
se estabelecer se não tiver linfócito ou
se ele fosse lá no tumor primário foi
instruída a montar uma estratégia que
não interfere com o osso
a gente não vai ter o estabelecimento de
tumor no osso mas outros teve um outro
grupo de pesquisadores que mostrou que
algumas estratégias que o montado de
expor e se ele fosse do coordenador né e
traça as estratégias de resposta do
sistema imune e que são diferentes das
estratégias que a gente viu o processo
podem ajudar por exemplo um tumor de
pulmão de mama também mostrando assim
dois sistemas diferentes que o iphoto
coordenador é super importante por
estabelecimento de imitar que a gente
tira disso né acho que a gente tira duas
coisas importantes
a primeira coisa é que realmente a gente
pode dizer que o sistema imune o câncer
podem ser parceiros e que é importante
nisso é que o sistema imune a ajuda não
só o tumor primário a se estabelecer mas
ajuda as metástases a se estabelecer
qual é a consequência disso pra gente
como a gente pode usar isso de uma
maneira prática né
a gente está tentando fazer agora se a
gente for capaz e assim tecnicamente é
possível fazer isso né de pegar os
linfócitos de um determinado indivíduo
que tem um determinado morro e saber
quais as estratégias que estes
linfócitos que estava em contato com o
tumor podem ter
a gente pode ser capaz de prevenir a
metástase para que órgãos poderão
acontecer
estou mostrando pra vocês como é que a
partir da ciência básica a gente pode
gerar um dado que é muito útil
clinicamente e que pode obviamente
melhorar a qualidade de vida dos
pacientes e aumentar a sobrevida já que
para algumas metais existem tratamentos
preventivos para outras não existem mas
a gente poderia fazer um rastreamento
precoce e detectar isso muito
precocemente obviamente isso vai
melhorar a qualidade de vida ea
sobrevida das pacientes
[Aplausos]